AND YOU'VE BEEN READING THROUGH
DONALD TRUMP JR.'S TRANSCRIPTS.
WHAT ARE YOU FINDING IN THERE?
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW, THIS IS
OBVIOUSLY INTERESTING BECAUSE
HE'S THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S SON,
PROXIMITY TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND ASKING HIM ABOUT
WHAT WAS HAPPENING AS THE RIOT
UNFOLDED ON JANUARY 6th AND
THEY'RE READING BACK TEXT
MESSAGES HE EXCHANGED WITH MARK
MEADOWS.
AT ONE POINT DON JUNIOR TELLS
MARK MEADOWS, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HIS DAD HAS GOT
TO CONDEMN THIS THEN SAYS AN
EXPLETIVE SO THE COMMITTEE IS
ASKING HIM, YOU KNOW, YOU SAID
HE'S GOT TO CONDEMN THIS.
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO CONDEMN AND
AGAIN, DON JUNIOR SAYS THE
VIOLENCE GOING ON, AGAIN, I
THINK I MADE IT PRETTY CLEAR IN
MY SPEECH WE CAN DO THIS
PEACEFULLY, YOU KNOW, USE YOUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS, DO IT
THAT WAY BUT VIOLENCE HAS NO
PLACE IN THIS SITUATION.
AND, ABBY, OF COURSE, WE KNOW
FROM OUR PREVIOUS REPORTING ON
THE MARK MEADOWS TEXT HOW THEY
WERE GETTING INUNDATED FROM
PEOPLE INCLUDING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT'S KIDS TRYING TO GET
DONALD TRUMP TO CALL OFF THE
MASSES AND IN THIS TRANSCRIPT,
DONALD TRUMP JR. POINTS OUT THAT
HE WAS OFTEN IN CONTACT WITH
OTHER WHITE HOUSE AIDES.
HE SAID WHEN HE TRIED TO REACH
HIS DAD AT THE WHITE HOUSE HE
WOULD OFTEN GET HIM THROUGH THE
WHITE HOUSE OPERATOR BECAUSE
FAMOUSLY HIS FATHER DOESN'T
TEXT, HIS FATHER DOESN'T USE
EMAILS, THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
HAS STYMIED A NUMBER OF
INVESTIGATORS, HIS LACK OF A
PAPER TRAIL AND YOU GET SOME
MORE INSIGHT INTO IT INTO THESE
TRANSCRIPTS AND ASKED DONALD
TRUMP JR. A LOT ABOUT THE
FUND-RAISING EFFORTS AND SAW THE
COMMITTEE MAKE A LOT OF HOW MUCH
MONEY DONALD TRUMP RAISED ON
THESE BASELESS CLAIMS OF
ELECTION FRAUD AND DONALD
TRUMP JR. SORT OF SAYS, YOU
KNOW, YOU COULD SEND OUT THINGS
UNDER MY NAME AS LONG AS THEY
WERE APPROVED BY LEGAL.
THAT WAS THE TACIT AGREEMENT.
HE WOULD OCCASIONALLY BEEN IN
TOUCH WITH BIG DONORS BUT
DIALING FOR DONORS WAS HIS IDEA
OF HELL.
>> A LOT OF INTERESTING THINGS.
A LOT OF I DON'T KNOWS AND I
DON'T RECALLS IN THESE
TRANSCRIPTS, AS WELL.
SARA, THANK YOU.
>>> LET'S DISCUSS NOW WITH
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR RENATO
MARIOTTI AND RON BROWNSTEIN.
RENATO, OBVIOUSLY IN THESE
TRANSCRIPTS, YOU'RE SEEING AN
EFFORT ESPECIALLY AS WE GET
CLOSER INTO TRUMP'S INNER CIRCLE
TO REALLY TRY TO NOT SAY
DEFINITIVELY WHETHER OR NOT A
LOT OF THINGS HAPPENED, BUT ONE
THING THAT HAS KIND OF STRUCK
OUT IN MANY OF THE TRANSCRIPTS
IS THE ROLE OF MARK MEADOWS WHO
WAS THE CHIEF OF STAFF AT THE
TIME.
HE WAS AT THE HEART OF A LOT OF
THIS BECAUSE HE WAS THE PERSON
PHYSICALLY CLOSEST TO THE
PRESIDENT.
WE ALSO LEARNED YESTERDAY
CASSIDY HUTCHINSON SAW HIM
THROWING PAPERS INTO A FIREPLACE
AND BURNING THEM.
FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE, WHAT'S
NEXT HERE FOR MARK MEADOWS?
IF YOU'RE THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
LOOKING INTO ALL OF THIS, IS
THERE MORE THAT YOU WANT TO
LEARN FROM HIM AND WILL THEY BE
ABLE TO GET THOSE ANSWERS?
>> IT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
I THINK THAT THE CHALLENGE FOR
JACK SMITH IS GOING TO BE THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT.
IF I WAS REPRESENTING MARK
MEADOWS, I WOULD COUNSEL HIM TO
TAKE THE FIFTH AND NOT TESTIFY
WHATSOEVER UNLESS HE RECEIVED
IMMUNITY.
I THINK THAT, YOU KNOW, THE
QUESTION IS REALLY GOING TO BE
FOR JACK SMITH, DOES HE HAVE
ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO GO TO
MEADOWS' DEFENSE COUNSEL WHO IS
A VERY FINE CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY AND SAY, I'M GOING TO
INDICT YOUR CLIENT IF HE DOES
NOT COOPERATE.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY THE
QUESTION HERE.
OTHERWISE, THE ALTERNATIVE WOULD
BE TO IMMUNIZE MEADOWS IN ORDER
TO GET HIS TESTIMONY AGAINST
TRUMP WHICH IS DANGEROUS BECAUSE
MEADOWS MAY TRY TO COVER FOR
TRUMP.
I WILL SAY BY THE WAY THAT I
THINK IT IS APPARENT, YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT, ABBY, FROM
READING THE TRANSCRIPTS HOW MUCH
MEADOWS WAS A KEY HERE.
HE WAS IN MANY WAYS A FUNNEL OR
A BOTTLENECK FOR SO MANY PEOPLE
TO REACH TRUMP THAT DAY.
>> AND, RON, I WANT TO JUST STAY
ON DON JUNIOR FOR A SECOND AND
THIS ISSUE OF HOW HE WAS ABLE TO
OR NOT ABLE TO GET TO HIS
FATHER.
IN THESE TRANSCRIPTS IT MAKES IT
VERY CLEAR THAT DON JUNIOR
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPERATIVE FOR
HIS FATHER TO GO TO THE OVAL
OFFICE AND SAY SOMETHING TO DO
SOMETHING, BUT HE COULDN'T GET
THROUGH TO TRUMP HIMSELF.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT, JUST
THE FACT THAT EVEN FOR THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S FAMILY, THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO GET THIS MESSAGE
THROUGH TO HIM AT SUCH A
CRITICAL MOMENT?
>> WELL, TO RENATO'S FIRST
POINT, IT IS ABOUT THE
CENTRALITY OF THE ROLE OF MARK
MEADOWS AND HOW HE WAS REALLY
THE HUB, I THINK, OR THE FUNNEL
FOR SO MUCH OF THIS INCLUDING
THE EFFORTS TO COMMUNICATE WITH
HIM, THE PRESIDENT, ON THAT DAY.
CAN I FOCUS, ABBY, ON ANOTHER --
FOLLOWING UP ON ANOTHER ASPECT
OF THE TRUMP JR. DEPOSITION THAT
I THINK IS REALLY CRITICAL
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW, I MEAN, I
DON'T KNOW, I DON'T RECALL, I
DON'T REMEMBER, IF YOU TAKE
THOSE WORDS OUT YOU MIGHT REDUCE
IT FROM 105 PAGES TO 5.
BUT THERE IS ONE CRITICAL THING,
THERE IS ONE CRITICAL THING THAT
HE ACKNOWLEDGES AND, YOU KNOW,
IN THE REPORT THE FIRST MENTION
OF THE IDEA OF HAVING STATE
REPUBLICAN CONTROL STATE
LEGISLATORS THROW OUT THE VOTE
IN THEIR STATE AND SIMPLY
SUBSTITUTE DONALD TRUMP ELECTORS
IS FROM DONALD TRUMP JR. TO MARK
MEADOWS TWO DAYS AFTER THE
ELECTION.
IT'S SOMEWHERE AROUND PAGE 260
OF THE REPORT.
AND IN THIS DEPOSITION, HE'S
ASKED, WHERE DID HE GET THAT
IDEA?
AND HE ACKNOWLEDGES THAT IT WAS,
QUOTE, A CUT AND PASTE FROM
SOMEONE ELSE, THAT HE DID NOT
DEVELOP THIS HIMSELF, BUT HE
SAYS I DON'T REMEMBER WHO GAVE
ME THE IDEA INITIALLY.
I'M GUESSING THAT AS THEY
INVESTIGATE THE FAKE ELECTOR
SCHEME AND THE BROADER
CONSPIRACY TO OBSTRUCT THE
OFFICIAL PROCEEDING THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS GOING TO WANT TO
PRESS DONALD TRUMP JR. ON RATHER
THAN JUST SIMPLY I DON'T
REMEMBER.
HE IS SAYING THAT IDEA, WHICH I
THINK IS THE FIRST TIME IT
APPEARS IN THE RECORD OF THAT
SUGGESTION AND MEADOWS RESPONDS,
WE ARE ALREADY WORKING ON IT.
SO I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
INSIGHT INTO THE GENESIS OF THE
FAKE ELECTOR SCHEME.
>> RENATO, I WONDER WHAT YOU
MAKE OF THAT AND ALSO THIS
TACTIC THAT YOU SEE REPEATEDLY
IN THESE TRANSCRIPTS FROM DON
JUNIOR, FROM OTHERS, KIMBERLY
GUILFOYLE CLOSE TO THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TO TRY TO SUGGEST THEY
JUST DON'T REMEMBER THINGS THAT
ARE THERE, HOW FAR DOES THAT GO
WHEN YOU'RE NOT A JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE BUT A FEDERAL
INVESTIGATOR PROBING SOME OF
THESE QUESTIONS?
>> WELL, IT'S NOT UNCOMMON,
ABBY, FOR WITNESSES TO TAKE THAT
APPROACH WHEN THERE'S A CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION, BECAUSE IT CAN BE
HARD TO DISPROVE WHAT YOU CAN OR
CAN'T REMEMBER AND SO IT'S HARD
TO CHARGE SOMEONE WITH LYING FOR
SAYING THAT THEY DON'T RECALL
AND THEY DON'T REMEMBER
SOMETHING SO THAT'S WHY THEY'RE
DOING IT.
I THINK ONE THING THAT STRUCK ME
WITH DON JUNIOR HE SOMETIMES
TAKES IT A STEP FURTHER AND
TRIES TO DISTANCE HIMSELF FROM
HIS FATHER WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
VERY INTERESTING.
HE COULDN'T REACH HIS FATHER
DIRECTLY, THAT'S WHY HE WENT TO
MEADOWS.
HE'S NOT REALLY INVOLVED OF THE
HE'S JUST THE FUND-RAISING GUY,
LOOK, HE MAKES HIMSELF SEEM LIKE
HE'S REALLY VERY DISTANT WHEREAS
OTHER MEDIA, OTHER TIMES IF YOU
READ HIS TWITTER FEED OR IF
YOU'RE GETTING HIS FUND-RAISING
EMAILS, WHICH I OCCASIONALLY DO
SOUNDS LIKE HE'S HAND IN GLOVE
WITH HIS FATHER LIKE THEY'RE
TALKING CONSTANTLY AND WORKING
TOGETHER AND HE'S THE HEIR
APPARENT SO, YOU KNOW, I THINK
IT'S INTERESTING, IT'S REALLY
INTERESTING WHEN YOU COMPARE IT
TO SOME OF THE OTHER WITNESSES
LIKE STEPHEN MILLER WHO KEPT
PUTTING HIS ARMS AROUND DONALD
TRUMP AND WAS SAYING HOW
GLORIOUS HE WAS AND STUCK WITH
THE PARTY LINE.
I THINK IT SHOWS THAT DON JUNIOR
REALLY SAW POTENTIAL CULPABILITY
FOR HIMSELF HERE.
>> RON, SPEAKING OF STEPHEN
MILLER THERE WAS ANOTHER KEY
QUOTE IN MILLER'S DEPOSITION.
HE WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS ELLIPSE
SPEECH THAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
6th AND MILLER TOLD THE
INVESTIGATORS ON THE COMMITTEE
THAT IT IS A, QUOTE, RADICAL
IMPOSSIBILITY AND EXTREME AND
OUTLANDISH TO SAY THAT TRUMP
WANTED ANYTHING BUT, QUOTE,
PEACE AND HARMONY ON JANUARY
6th.
JUST YOUR REACTION ON ITS FACE
TO THAT STATEMENT FROM STEPHEN
MILLER.
>> WELL, LOOK, STEPHEN MILLER IS
THE PURIFIED ESSENCE OF
TRUMPISM.
YOU KNOW, EMBODIMENT AND AN
INDIVIDUAL WE CONTINUE TO SEE IT
IN THE CAUSES THAT HE HAS PUSHED
THE GROUP THAT HE WAS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT HAD THOSE OPENLY
RACIST ADS DURING THE BASEBALL
PLAYOFFS ABOUT THE BORDER AND SO
FORTH AND, LOOK, IT IS JUST A
REMINDER THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
PORTION OF THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
STILL THAT IS GOING TO DEFEND
DONALD TRUMP TO THE LAST, YOU
KNOW, THE LAST YARD, EVEN AFTER
THE EVIDENCE, YOU KNOW, AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN THIS ELECTION IN
SWING STATES, THE CANDIDATES WHO
ARE ESSENTIALLY RUNNING UNDER
HIS UMBRELLA.
I LOOKED AT STEPHEN MILLER'S
DEPOSITION AS AN INDICATION OF
HOW HARD IT IS GOING TO BE FROM
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TO SIMPLY
PUT DONALD TRUMP IN THE REARVIEW
MIRROR NO MATTER HOW MANY
FUND-RAISERS AND OTHER PARTY
STRATEGISTS WANT TO DO SO.
THERE IS A CORE THAT IS DEEPLY
INVESTED IN HIS POLARIZING AND
DIVISIVE BRAND OF POLITICS AND
MILLER IS A REFLECTION OF THAT.
>> RENATO, ONE OF THE NEW PIECES
OF INFORMATION THAT WE'RE
GETTING IS FROM ACTUALLY THE
TRANSCRIPT OF CHRISTINA BOBB,
WHO IS RELAYING TO THE COMMITTEE
IN HER TESTIMONY SOME
CONVERSATIONS THAT SHE HAD WITH
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WHO, AS
YOU KNOW, IS A CLOSE ALLY OF
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S AND
THIS SEEMS TO KIND OF SPEAK TO
DESIRE ON THE PART OF SO MANY
PEOPLE AROUND TRUMP TO FIND
FRAUD WHERE THERE WAS NONE.
CHRISTINA SAYS THAT LINDSEY
GRAHAM TELLS HER TO JUST GIVE ME
FIVE DEAD VOTERS, GIVE ME -- I'M
SORRY.
THAT GRAHAM TOLD MEADOWS THIS,
BUT SHE TOLD THE COMMITTEE, GIVE
ME FIVE DEAD VOTERS, FIND AN
EXAMPLE OF LEGAL'S VOTING.
GIVE ME A SMALL SNAPSHOT, HE
SAYS, OF ANYTHING THAT HE CAN
TAKE AND CHAMPION IN ORDER TO
FIND -- IN ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE
EVIDENCE OF FRAUD AND AS WE
KNOW, THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE OF
FRAUD BUT WHAT DOES IT TELL YOU
THAT SOMEONE LIKE A SITTING
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM WAS
BASICALLY BEGGING FOR EXAMPLES
OF ANYTHING THAT WOULD PROVE
THESE BASELESS CLAIMS THAT THE
ELECTION WAS STOLEN?
>> YEAH, IT CERTAINLY MAKES IT
LOOK LIKE SOMETHING I THINK WE
ALREADY KNEW IS THAT HE WAS ON
TEAM TRUMP AND WAS WILLING TO DO
WHAT HE COULD TO TRY TO HELP
TRUMP CREATE ENOUGH OF A CIRCUS
AROUND THE ELECTORAL RESULTS TO
TRY TO OVERTURN THE RESULTS OF
THE ELECTION AND SO ONE THING
THAT I FIND JUST LOOKING AT IT
AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR AND A
CURRENT DEFENSE ATTORNEY IS, HOW
DOES THIS LINE UP WITH WHAT HE
TOLD THE FULTON COUNTY
PROSECUTOR?
YOU KNOW, THERE HE'S --
SUPPOSEDLY HE'S HAVING PHONE
CALLS TO GEORGIA TRYING TO
INFLUENCE THINGS OVER THERE AND
HE'S PROBABLY TRYING TO TAKE THE
TACT THAT DON JUNIOR WAS, I
DON'T REMEMBER MUCH.
WHAT DOE